[Music]
for centuries the angelic tones of a
choir have echoed within these
historical Cathedral walls but this
Sunday it's eerily quiet for the first
time since the 17th century Norwich
Cathedral has had to close its doors
over the last 4 months there's been no
prayers here no space for reflection and
no soaring voices of the choir our
cathedrals over the last few months have
just gone entirely silent because the
Cathedral choirs have not been out to
sing and at the same time cathedrals
have been using huge amounts of income
and so gonna really struggle to get
their choirs back on board
[Music]
instead they've come together to produce
this a lockdown song to help protect the
future of choirs 269 vocalists from 44
cathedrals and choral foundations across
the country banded together filming
themselves on their phones in their
living rooms and bedrooms they then sent
their parts to here in Norwich Cathedral
where the video was put together and
sent out to the rest of the UK Ashley is
the master of music here and arranged
this charity single this is a wonderful
opportunity to gather choristers
together from across the country from
all cathedrals are up and down the land
and if you like get them to sing with
one united voice even though they're
separated of course in their own homes
I'm supremely confident that this
tradition is not going to die out but
certainly the months ahead are very very
testing ones
the money raised will be part of the
Cathedral choirs emergency fund a
specific parts of cash to help these
grand institutions through tough times
ahead I think part of the difficulty is
the love of uncertainty and how I just
really don't know when it's gonna come
back and you know I really I do wanted
to come back as soon as possible the
choir may be geographically separated
but this song has brought them together
to make the largest group of choristers
in the country they now want to be
together in cathedrals where they belong
in some a machined Sky News in Norwich